looking at that guy you're looking at
the guy that all the other girls are
attracted to
right not you know you're attracted to
the average dude yeah i'm gonna go the
opposite way if i see all the girls
going to one guy i'm saying it puts me
off yeah exactly i'm like he gets hella
girl's ego's probably up here i'm trying
to be away from away that it puts me off
women generally oh all right do you uh
hmm
stop the cat now right so stop the cat
because women generally
okay so when you all right so no i'll
tell you why because the statistics
don't
the statistics don't um fare in your
favor because there's a top percentage
of men right when a women are asked the
type of man that they want right for
instance if you go to kevin samuels
right he would ask women generally what
type of man do you want and all the
women generally would ask for a certain
type of man and that man is in the top
percentage of what the general
population of men is so it's known that
women tend to go
for the same type of man that um
that i guess adheres to a certain
percentage the other general men women
aren't looking for
so that's why i say that because when it
comes to the percentage if i was to ask
you all now what type of man do you want
does your man have to be earning a
certain amount does he have to be taller
what's his height um what does his
personality have to be like you'd
probably all have similar men that you
like
the average guy doesn't get a look
yeah let's do it okay so if i was to ask
you
what i'm oh this is this this is this is
in the spirit of kevin this is the
spirit of kevin samuels right
so experiment the spirit of kevin
samuels is is you know he's dead but not
gone um so if i was to say okay how much
does a man have to be earning
um
i don't have a number but i've always
said that as long as you're financially
stable and you kind of know what you're
going towards i'm not fine with that you
don't have to be only like 30 40 like i
don't have a number to it because with
in this day and age it's a bit techy but
i'm not going to sit with someone that's
at home doing nothing i've got nothing
going for them okay so you want a man
that's earning five grand a year what
the f
whoa right that because because
everyone's got a number that's what i'm
trying to say if you if you say five
grand a year depends on how like i think
i'll say like how you're earning your
money and what you're getting your money
if it's something where you're just
starting and that's what you're earning
i can see where you're going with it
because it's not that's not what it is
you're working towards something no job
is paying you five grand a year namely a
job that's paying you five no but i'm
saying no it's not it's not a job you
could be on a job seekers allowance i
don't know yeah but that's what if for
example
if he's on job seekers allowance my
thing is you're on that for now to try
and sort something out you're not on
that forever
that's my point yeah but the but the
question i'm asking is there's a
definitely a minimum that a man has to
be making per year right i've never
actually thought about that
to be honest so i've never all right so
so so we know that you don't want a man
that's making five grand a year i mean
i'm not too fussed if you've got
something going for you like that's not
your so you want a broke man not
absolutely financially financially
stable and a year is not financially
safe yeah but financially stable we live
in london right mm-hmm so to be quote
financially to
to be quote unquote financially stable
you need to be earning a certain amount
of money to be quote-unquote financially
stable five grand right okay so it's
above that then right that's why i'm
trying to ask for a number everyone's
acting like they don't know what a
number is it i've been so serious
personally i've never thought about
people my thing is if you ever ask me
i've always said as long as you're
financially stable and like you kind of
have something going for you i'm not mad
i'm not mad at it whereas if it's a film
where you're not financially stable
you're not doing anything about it
you're sitting at home and you're
chilling i'm not for that so that's
always been my feeling that i'm not
trying to raise a man either but i need
you to at least have a sense of
something of where you're trying to go
so you have no number in your head about
what a man personally do you have a
number in your head that i must make
because i'm going to go around and see
if there's a number i don't i don't have
this you can be honest i don't have a
specific i don't have a specific number
i love it it's just it depends on our
future
i don't have
like you said percentage that's going to
be probably the top one percent
wouldn't say it wouldn't say it but
that's not because i'm not that's not
what i need though no but say it i'm
talking about being honest i live in
london out i'm thinking about what i
make let's say
if we're matching
the facade they don't want to break the
facade you don't want to break the
visage
but i can turn up okay let's say just be
honest just be honest i'm thinking if if
we're together
if we're together and we're cold we're
in a relationship called like if if i'm
working
because if a man wants me to stay at
home let's say one wants to stay at home
he's always gonna have to make some
a lot more than yeah an average amount
so but if i've asked for a number about
two minutes ago
50k all right cool thank you there you
go
what's up
with that
in accordance
what number
what number
i don't even know what money i want to
be making in the future i actually have
no clue but that's that's not the
question
that's not the question i ask
i don't know what like as long as
they're like chilling
they're not starving you know ladies
just be honest
asking questions
one thing i'll say is when you're in uni
or when you're under like the age of 25
yeah um certain things like money aren't
really a factor
so like yeah we get given the fact that
you really want to be asking our height
um
looks okay um it's it's those kind of
factors at this current moment in their
stage because they're not they're not
thinking about um
money you're not thinking about money
they're not thinking about security
when you think about me okay we're a bit
older than not that much older but
they're still young
so it's like the question you're asking
them ideally they'll probably want a guy
that's making a lot of money but
at the moment they they can't really say
i want this man at this time because i'm
not doing that okay so let's go to
height and what's the height of demand
that you i've always said as long as
you're taller than me in hills
so how tall are you i'm five four and
how tall are you in heels probably like
five six five seven so a six foot man i
thought five nine five eight okay five
nine yeah two right um five nine so
anything like five ten five eleven five
ten five nine
yeah the same
yeah
yeah like six
so basically you want a man that's
genuinely taller than you yeah
so when i said so the average man is
probably about five eight it's probably
about us about
about five eight so when i said there
that generally women want the same kind
of man you all want the same type of man
that's about around six foot
right around six foot because you said
you're what five seven okay you don't
have to be six foot to be taller than me
you i can't take a five eight ladies you
want you you you kind of want the same
man we don't want this word
you kind of want the same man highway no
no do you want a lady taller than you
yeah
some moderator men are going to ask
taylor's ladies shoot them yes i'm
saying so i think we all
i'm okay with that i'm okay with that
it's like you're it's like you're not
okay with saying yeah i want a six-foot
man when that's actually what you want
you want a six-foot man
i don't want nor do i need i just want i
want someone who's taller than me if
he's six four then he's six foot yeah
as long as he's taller than me that's
what i find attractive i won't cut you
off because you're not six foot yeah
yeah
with a measuring tape
we're talking about the ideal
you're ideal man yeah yeah yeah yeah
taller than me yeah i'm quite sure so
yeah i i don't mind
why are we saying that six foot six foot
is tall it's not that what i'm saying
so it's not two i'm over six
all my exes are six foot six oh